CBC came back yesterday, everything fell into the normal range except my fasting glucose was 205 and my hemoglobin A1c was 6.0.
This falls into the pre-diabetic range, correct?
No, that actually falls into the full diabetic range.
So if you had a 12 hour fast and your glucose is 205, that's not a good thing.
So we got to start investigating this.
I would like to look at, we should have a conversation to schedule an appointment.
Technically, legally, glucose over a 12 hour fasting glucose over 125 for more than two consecutive blood tests is considered diabetes.
So then when they came out with the hemoglobin A1c test, that's more of a specific test for long term glucose.
We want to see that really below 5.5, at least, and yours being 6 is still elevated.
So why concern what would be causing that elevated fasting glucose? So typically, you don't see an elevated fasting glucose.
If you're fasting glucose of 205 unless the person has diabetes or something else going on, can be an error in the test.
If all your other CBCs were all within normal limits and nothing was changed or your diet wasn't changed, nothing happened, and now you're at this spike, I mean, I would run it again.
It's real easy to go get a glucometer at the target or a Walmart or something with the little prick, pin prick things and test your own fasting glucose to see if this is an abnormality or something was wrong with the lab.
But that's abnormal.
And the follow-up question I'm currently doing two green juices a day. I want to add apple and carrot, but wonder if it's too sweet.
I should stay away from it. I would say with the fasting glucose of 205, I would not be adding apple and carrot juice right now. We got to figure this out something going on there.
Hopefully it's just a lab error.